we're trying to measure gravity between
two microscopic objects so micron sized
objects one millionth of a meter in size
so about one one-hundredth the width of
a human hair I'm we do this by actually
levitating a glass sphere that's five
microns in diameter in a high vacuum
chamber and we levitate it with a laser
so actually the laser the photons or the
light in the laser pushes on the
microsphere or this 5 micron glass
sphere hard enough to hold it up against
gravity and float it in the center of
our vacuum chamber and because it's then
sitting in our vacuum chamber we can
decouple it from all the forces that you
would get if you were in the environment
and you had air pushing against you and
other things that could degrade the
ability to see these very tiny forces
from gravitational interactions or
gravity like interactions that we're
looking for so to do this we need we
need lasers we need to be able to have
an optical table where we can take a
laser focus it inside of our vacuum
chamber once we bring the light to a
focus then you get a very intense laser
light which is strong enough to hold up
this microsphere against gravity we then
actually drop these microspheres in
vacuum so we smear them onto the bottom
of a glass coverslip we shake that cover
slip very hard and some of these
microspheres fall off and they fall
under gravity and a very tiny fraction
of them will actually fall through this
micron size focus of our laser so the
analogy might be that it's like dropping
a basketball off the Empire State
Building and expecting it to fall
through the hoop on the ground floor so
once so this this happens very rarely
but obviously we can drop very many of
these microspheres and some of them will
fall through that hoop and become
trapped once they're trapped then
they're very well decoupled from the
environment and we can see these
extremely tiny forces that we want to
see interacting on them so we bring a
dense test mass nearby so a gold test
mass or a very dense material that's
also microns in size two micron
separations and then we look for some
attractive force as we start to get that
test mass very near the microsphere
that's held in our laser trap